welcome to this course on convolution
neural networks computer vision is one
of the area's that's been advancing
rapidly thanks to deep learning deep
learning computer vision is now helping
self-driving cars figure out where are
the other cars and the pedestrians
around it so it's avoid them
is making face recognition work much
better than ever before so that perhaps
some of you will soon or perhaps already
be able to unlock a phone unlock even a
door using just your face and if you
look on your cell phone I bet you many
apps that show you pictures of food or
pictures of Aalto or just fun pictures
of scenery and some of the companies
that build those apps are using deep
learning to he'll show you the most
attractive of the most beautiful or the
most relevant pictures and I think deep
learning is even enabling new types of
art to be created so I think the two
reasons I'm excited about deep learning
frequency vision and why I think you
might be to first rapid advances in
computer vision are enabling brand new
applications to be built they just were
impossible a few years ago and by
learning these tools perhaps you will be
able to invent some of these new
products and applications second even if
you don't end up building computer
vision systems per se I found that
because the computer vision research
community has been so creative and so
inventive and coming up with new neural
network architectures new algorithms is
actually inspire that creates a lot of
cross-fertilization
into other areas as well for example
when those work on speech recognition I
sometimes actually took inspiration from
ideas from computer vision and borrowed
them into the speech literature so even
if you don't end up working on confusion
I hope that you find some of the ideas
you learn about in this course hopeful
for some of your algorithms and your
your architectures so with that let's
get started
here are some examples of computer
vision problems we'll study in this
course you've already seen image
classification sometimes also called
image recognition where you might take
as input say a 64 by 64 image and try to
figure out if static at another example
of a computer vision problem is object
detection so if you're building a
self-driving car maybe you don't just
need to figure out if there are other
cars in this image but instead you need
to figure out the position of the other
cars in this picture so that your car
you can avoid them so an object
detection usually we have to not just
figure out that these other objects say
cause in the picture but also draw boxes
around them or have some other way of
recognizing where in the picture are
these objects and notice also in this
example that there can be multiple cars
in the same picture or at least every
one of them within a certain distance of
your car here's another example maybe a
more fun one is nearest our transfer
let's say you have a picture and you
want this picture repaint it in a
different style
so nearest our transfer you have a
content image and you have a style image
the image on the right does se a Picasso
and you can have a neural network put
them together to repaint the content
image that is the image on the left but
in the style of the image on the right
and you end up with the image at the
bottom so albums like these are enabling
new types of artwork to be created and
in this course you learn how to do this
yourself as well one of the challenges
of computer vision problems is that the
inputs can get really big for example in
previous courses you've worked with 64
by 64 images and so that's 64 by 64 by 3
because they're three colour channels
and if you multiply that out that's one
two two eight eight so X the input
features has dimension one to two eight
eight and that's not too bad but 64 by
64 is actually very small image if you
work with larger images maybe this is a
thousand pixel by thousand pixel image
and that's actually just some one mega
pixel but the dimension of the input
features will be thousand by thousand by
three because you have three RGB
channels and that's three million oh and
if you are viewing this on a smaller
screen this might not be apparent but
this is actually low res 64 by 64 image
and this is a higher-risk
thousand by thousand image
but if you have three million input
features then this means that X here
would be three million dimensional and
so if in the first hidden layer maybe
you have just a thousand hidden units
then the total number of weights that is
the matrix w1 if you use a standard
fully connected Network like we have in
closest one or two this matrix will be a
one thousand by three million
dimensional matrix right because X is um
now R by 3 million VM I'm using to
denote 3 million and this means that
this matrix here will have 3 billion
parameters which is just very very large
and with that many parameters is
difficult to get enough data to prevent
in your network from overfitting and
also the computational requirements and
the memory requirements to train the
neural network with the billion
parameters is just a bit infeasible but
for computer vision applications you
don't want to be stuck using only tiny
little images you want to use large
images to do that you need to better
implement the convolution operation
which is one of the fundamental building
blocks of convolutional neural networks
let's see what this means and how you
can implement this in the next video and
we'll illustrate convolutions using the
example of H detection